[Music]
[Applause]
uh he's Trevor Lawrence the Jags
quarterback former number one overall
pick joining us on behalf of Gatorade uh
Jags lost to the Eagles in week four and
to the Chiefs in week 10 and of course
in the AFC division I don't know why I'm
bringing that up I perfect let's go back
to Clemson and start talking about some
of those silence say hello to Trevor
Lawrence who joins us here
foreign
[Applause]
we just had uh Justin Herbert on and uh
we thought we would have a uh a hair off
here so where do you rank him hair wise
as far as he's up there he's up there I
think uh definitely
I don't know I haven't thought about the
hairless but he'd be he'd be up there
okay how often does your hair come up in
conversation a lot yeah probably once uh
whether it's you know on a show or an
interview probably once every time I
talk to somebody but if you decide to
cut it you have to run it by your wife
if you just said you know what
definitely oh yeah yeah she's so I had a
I had a bus cut in eighth grade and she
was not a fan of that so it's been
there's a picture there's pictures
there's pictures that you guys could
find I'm sure
um not great so I'm gonna I'm gonna keep
it as long as I can but do you want to
do like uh Matthews with his hair like
is there a certain length no this is
about it like I'll I'll let it get here
and I'll trim it every couple months no
ponytails no no no no because you don't
want somebody to grab your hair while
you're running oh I hope not hasn't
happened yet so it kind of tucks into my
shoulder pads a little bit so it kind of
stays it's illegal now to grab Herod no
Polly actually I don't think so I think
they say if your hair goes out the back
of your helmet and someone wants to grab
it that is not like the horse collar
it's on you I think that's right yeah
it's part of the does that affect your
decision uniform or whatever yeah I
don't know
can you
walk around Jacksonville
yeah do you wear disguises no no not
around not around Jacksonville I mean of
course there's people that'll stop you
and want to say hey and talk to you
which is part of it but I think honestly
Jacksonville has been pretty good about
it's not like a huge city as far as like
downtown and you know really populated
like it's kind of spread out over at the
beaches so you'll run into people every
once in a while but people do a good job
of just kind of letting you have your
space you know it's been one thing
that's been good you ever get confused
for somebody else
not really no no actor no no actress
well not not no neither one of those but
I did actually when we were in La last
year for the Super Bowl
um I think TMZ posted one thing and they
tagged me as Leonardo DiCaprio which I
had never gotten that before so I don't
look like him at all but I'll take it as
a compliment so that'd be hard to
explain to your wife if you're Leo with
with his dating situation there yeah
well luckily you know Marissa's in the
picture okay there's no no issues it was
just funny it was just funny uh you
played both of these teams if uh you
were gonna take like one thing out from
both teams that you go that surprised us
what would it be if I start with the
Chiefs what surprised you you know I
think I wouldn't say it surprised me we
had a good feel for it going in but I do
think that I've said it before I think
their defense is really underrated you
know obviously Chris Jones is really
really good up front he makes it
difficult just protections Run game you
know he's a guy that can that can wreck
a game
um so Chris Jones is great and then just
their scheme and their secondary's been
playing really well
um they have a really good pressure
package you know I'll be interested to
see what they do against the Chiefs the
Chiefs or I'm sorry the Eagles the
Eagles Run game is so good
um I'll be interested to see how much
they pressure kind of what they do but I
think that's one part of their team
that's that's underrated just their
defense as the whole okay and then the
Eagles
Eagles I mean obviously everybody talks
about their defense the pass rush I
think pairing that with the play of
their secondary makes it difficult for
offenses because you know they get to
the quarterback so fast it's hard to run
the ball but then their guys in the back
end can hold up as well so when you have
that pass rush and guys that can cover
um it makes it makes it tough how many
times you go to the line of scrimmage
and you go I have no idea what this
defense is going to do
you know not not a ton I think
definitely the Chiefs are a team where
they make they try to make everything
look the same so it's tough to it's
tough to tell when they're gonna bring
you know saw Blitz off both edges or
they're going to drop into cover four
they make everything look the same so
that's a defense where it's a little
challenging but how many times do you go
up there and you go oh my gosh this is a
touchdown
quite a few especially when when you
have well when you have uh like
especially in the Red Zone yeah you have
certain plays like we want this specific
coverage and well give me one that we
can now look back on that highlight and
and we know that you go to the line of
scrimmage and you know it's going to be
a touchdown well when we played the
Chiefs actually the touchdown through
the Christian in the Red Zone we put
them in the backfield he ran basically
like a wheel route out of the backfield
and I saw
they like to bring a lot of pressure
when you get down in the Red Zone
especially lower and they I could tell
they were bringing like some type of
overload zero pressure and that's what
we wanted to get Christian matched up on
the D end who had to peel with him and I
saw them creeping before the snap so I
knew they made me hot so I just had to
drift a little bit but do you have to
hide your excitement a little bit I mean
you just gotta you gotta make sure you
make the throw make the play you know
give it give them a catchable ball
that's the biggest thing is yeah I think
early especially my rookie year and even
earlier last season you see one of those
like we had one similar situation
against the commanders where it was with
Travis though out of the backfield and
almost the same route just further out
in the red zone and just overthrew it by
like five yards because got too excited
and didn't give him a good throw give me
a complicated play call
can you complicated play call yeah well
you want me to give you the whole play
call I don't have to explain it right
you don't have to hear all the uh no no
just just we're in the middle play call
well you guys might have seen the clip
from NFL films I don't know if you saw
the Long play call that we had anyways
but one would be like comfy left Buster
63 bang z Maui alert 63 trying to put a
kill on him that would go with it it
would be alert 63 Paradise Z Burger y
wrap and that'd be one call and then you
just
and that that's that's for different
coverages if you want if I need to alert
it
um based on you know we have certain man
Zone indicators all that so you see it
out of the Huddle and then I give
everybody the alert and everybody knows
it's switching to the second play or
vice versa oh my God and then you can
reload it if
say you alert it and the defense then
changes back then you just reload it
then it goes back to the first place
everybody really has to know what you're
talking about or you can get lost really
quick yeah well now I really feel sorry
for Christian McCaffrey as he's trying
to play quarterback against the Eagles
and you've got that wrist they have some
of the longest play calls too so Kyle
Shanahan yeah I heard I heard that
because I you know CJ beathard guy one
of my teammates good friends he played
there so he he told me some long long
calls what's the shortest play call
um
is that just quarterback's knee I mean a
lot the Run game typically if it's
simple formations like especially if
we're Tempo on the ball it'll just be
like you know well that's 14 15. might
have its tag like 14 waist whatever it
might be it's it's pretty short have you
uh ever forgot the play at the line of
scrimmage
forgot it no there's been a couple times
where I've you know called in the Huddle
off the wristbands we have the super
long ones Around The Wristband we'll
call it then I'll get up there and I
start my Cadence and then I'm like okay
well he was running the like because you
have a different because we have our you
know I know our Concepts but then we'll
tag certain things and when you tag a
receiver it's basically switching their
responsibilities so like I'll look and
be like okay so he's running there then
I have to get it right with a snap that
doesn't happen a ton but it does happen
sometimes and and there are certain
quarterbacks who have the great presence
with their voice like Dan Marino has a
great presence when he would get to line
of scrimmage you ever like voice crack a
little bit when you're trying to yell
yeah I had one uh against I think it was
against the Titans when we played in
Tennessee that was really bad Evan Evan
Ingram you know after uh the play he
came up to me in the HUD and was like
did your did your voice crack
but it cracked cracked for like five
seconds long it was like the longest
voice crack ever so so you're calling
out the play at the line no it's just in
my case yeah so you went up yeah
exactly exactly Trevor Lawrence joining
us the Jags quarterback how much do you
mature like they talk about the game
slowing down I don't know how long it
takes or you've we're told that okay
it'll slow down and now you see it
differently
um has it flown it slowed down uh you
know differently than the first year
definitely I think also too as you get
more comfortable in the system obviously
that helps so I think as the season went
on
you know I think you saw that in our
offense probably the Midway point of our
season
I think it really started to slow down
for me and for the just our whole
offense guys and the chemistry like
that's one thing it takes a while when
especially when you have new players
guys that haven't played together before
and it's a new system it takes a while
to get that chemistry and to really know
what each other's thinking you know
playing and play out and I think we
developed that as the season went on but
I definitely feel like the game slowed
down a lot and I also know what I'm
looking for like I think a rookie year I
didn't always have necessarily
the best plan for it to of attack for
myself like okay what am I looking for
what's my clear thought process every
play and you got to have that every play
how important is it to have Doug who
played the position as your head coach
it's great you know just the the
understanding that he has he's been in
my shoes he's been back there obviously
played the position
had a lot of success you know won a
Super Bowl as a player one as a coach so
just knowing those experiences that he's
had and the way he carries himself you
can tell that he has been in this
position he's played quarterback and
he's really calm you know even Keel
that's one thing I really appreciate
about him I think that's why we get
along so well personality wise we're
really similar so
um it's been awesome just having him and
just that confidence that he has and
myself and our guys has been great but
could you pick up something from Brady
watching highlights
and could you say oh gosh okay he's
doing that now like I don't can you you
what are you you're asking like can I
tell what he's doing no could you could
you say now I can add that to my Arsenal
like I'm seeing some you know Rogers and
Mahomes do things where you go I don't
know how many guys can do that for sure
no I think
definitely I mean I think you can learn
something from all those guys that are
great great players especially Tom who's
a guy that you can just tell his
preparation I mean is second to none
he's always but what's that mean that
does he study more than you do well I'd
have to ask him what is I don't know
what is his uh talk about his
preparation but I I mean you can just
tell the way he plays the game
um I mean and the fact that you know
he's not very mobile can't move great
but he's doesn't take a lot of sacks
gets the ball out super quick if you
look at you know his from catch to
release time I mean I'm sure it's the
highest until he gets the ball out so
fast it doesn't give guys a chance to
pass rush he knows where his Outlets are
I think that's one thing he's so good at
getting the ball to his check Downs you
know quickly I think those are all
things that I've definitely tried to
take from watching him as you know just
get find completions that's what he's so
good at is just finding completions
every place not looking for the big shot
you know when it's there he's going to
take it because he knows that's what you
do but also he's not going to sit back
there and hold the ball hold the ball
two years older than you I know he's
yeah how old's your dad my dad is 51 one
okay so yeah could your dad beat Tom in
a race
uh I don't think so I don't think so you
don't think no I don't think so no I'm
gonna say no I'm just gonna say no
actually
are you more
um entertained by what Mahomes does or
Aaron Rodgers does
well uh
that's a tough question I think they're
different but probably
probably save my homes you know that's
just because that's a guy I've played
against now twice this season
seen it firsthand you know I haven't
played against Aaron yet but I mean
they're definitely in that same category
of just the wow factor the plays they
they can make there's definitely two
unique players where like you said you
don't see stuff that they do and think
I'm gonna try that this week I mean some
things you know some things you could
maybe do but not you can't play like
like them necessarily because everyone
has a different style and it's hard to
replicate what what Patrick can do but
have you tried the no look pass that
Mahomes does in practice so in practice
a little bit okay not a ton especially
like warming up if we're messing around
like yeah get some of the guys that are
catching I won't even look at them
surprising with the ball but not not in
a game I've done that yet are you uh
gonna watch the game yeah I'm gonna
watch it okay I'm not gonna be there in
person I'm not gonna put myself through
that pain of being there watching in
person I'm watching on TV but yeah
hopefully you don't invite people over
who don't know football so then they're
asking you questions the entire time no
I'm actually going to Christian
Christian Kirk okay his fiance live out
here okay
um we're gonna go hang out with them so
it'll be good tell us what you're doing
with uh Gatorade yeah I'm here with
Gatorade
um got our new drink fast twitch it's
funny we've been drinking this all year
and I told I told our Gatorade uh people
that we've been struggling to keep it in
stock in our facility so but you're this
is in conjunction with the NFL isn't it
do what Gatorade is incon the first one
I think that they've done in conjunction
with the league itself yeah obviously
it's it's Gatorade is the sponsor the
fish sponsor of the NFL so
um it's in conjunction with that and I'm
just excited like I said we've been
drinking It All season before it even
came out so we were trying to keep it in
stock and we run out so now I'm glad
we're going to be able to get more of it
in Jacksonville so what's it do it's
energy so it's like 200 200 milligrams
of caffeine it's just basically clean
energy drink you know we'll drink it
before practice before games all that so
you ever get two jacked up so yeah after
200 milligrams is like it's like right
on right on the line it's it's perfect
amount but I have to space it out drink
like half of it it can pre-game like
right before I go out and throw
initially and then the other half before
we go out for the game so well yeah I I
could imagine then you probably get to
the line discrimination you're speaking
so fast
[Laughter]
I know as a quarterback that's like you
don't want too much caffeine like that's
the one everyone else can kind of get
like we'll have guys that drink two of
these three of these and game day I'm
like I don't know Gatorade probably
would not recommend that I'm not saying
you should drink two or three of those
so 600 milligrams there of yeah a lot a
lot of caffeine but it's uh fast twitch
new energy drink from Gatorade and
exclusively available to NFL athletes
during the season now available in
stores nationwide uh thank you for being
available during the year we appreciate
your insights your sense of humor and
congrats on a uh on a wonderful season
yes sir thank you guys for having me
enjoyed it appreciate y'all yeah we'll
be back after this in The Dan Patrick
Show